हुआ था नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि
नए एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है इस सेगमेंट
कम बोलने वाले हैं वैन सड़क हंस सेट कि हर
बुधवार को छोटे-बड़े इंपोर्टेंट जर्मन
कंसेप्ट सीखेंगे हर रविवार को हमारा जो
मैं वीडियो है वह आएगा ही पर दूध और कौन
छोटे-छोटे कंसेप्ट सीखेंगे तो आज की
छोटी-बड़ी इंपोर्टेंट है सारे कंटीन्यूअस
टेंस जर्मन में फ्री में फ्री में मतलब
कुछ नया नहीं सीखेंगे हम आंच पर आपको सारे
कंटेंस्टेंट आएंगे शुरू करते हैं तो सबसे
पहले समझ लेते हैं वह थिस कंटिन्यूज है
मैं क्रिकेट खेल रहा हूं मैं क्रिकेट खेल
रहा था इस इन्हें क्या हो रहा है क्रिया
भी चल रही है मैं क्रिकेट खेल रहा हूं
प्रिया शुरू है इसलिए इसको थे कंटीन्यूअस
टेंस इसको इंग्लिश में कैसे होता है देखो
कि इस प्ले इन क्रिकेट
हैं या फिर बाय एम्पलाईिंग क्रिकेट तुमने
क्या किया एसएम आब्जर्वर लगाए और इन किया
जर्मन यह सब करना ही नहीं जर्मन में की
स्पेलिंग क्रिकेट का सिंपल बन जाता है कि
प्लेस क्रिकेट एग्स पेंट क्रिकेट को ईंधन
शेट्टी ने जब इस वगैरह लगाना ही नहीं ऐड
स्पीड क्रिकेट अभी कुछ जगह पर उसके उसके
यहां गिड़गिड़ाने लगाते हैं अभी बोलने के
लिए ऐड्स पेशेंट क्रिकेट ग्राउंड पर ए
कंपलसरी नहीं है इसलिए हम सिंपल रखेंगे
एडम्स पेट क्रिकेट अब यह याद रखने के लिए
कितना कुछ सिंपल एग्जांपल लेता हूं
एग्जांपल से याद रहता है सबको विड्रॉल का
टैलंट पता होगा है मिलाएंगे यह आई लव यू
गेट योर है जर्मन में तो है एम लविंग इट
तो क्या बनेगा आई लव इट और इसलिए बनेगा इस
लीवर इस तो अगर आप जर्मनी के किसी
कैंडी क्रश में जाओगे तो टैगलाइन दिखेगा
इस लीवर दूसरी बात ही नहीं है तो ही वास
प्लेयिंग रिकॉर्ड नहीं है ही है इस प्लेन
टिकट नहीं है कि हैव बीन प्लेयिंग क्रिकेट
नहीं है और इन फ्री विप्लेयर क्रिकेट नहीं
है हम आराम से देखते हैं सबसे पहले कि वॉच
प्लेन क्रिकेट ही नहीं की प्लेट स्पिरिट
ऑफ क्रिकेट ही असली क्रिकेट क्रिकेट
क्रिकेट टीम अब
चीन हस बीन प्लेयिंग क्रिकेट ही असली
क्रिकेट टेस्ट क्रिकेट की स्पीड और हैव
बीन प्लेयिंग किक्रेट
है कि हर प्लेट क्रिकेटर एयर होस्टेस
क्रिकेट गेम्स पेड़ सिंपल है न कुछ भी
नहीं सीखा हमने हमको तब बोलना आ गया एकदम
सिंपल कंसेप्ट है कंटीन्यूअस टेंस है ही
नहीं सिर्फ इंपॉर्टेंट एग्जांपल क्या याद
रखना है आई एम लविंग इट आई लव इट इस लीवर
तो आज देखो हमने कुछ भी नया नहीं सीखा पर
हमने क्या सिखा जर्मन में कंटीन्यूअस टेंस
है ही नहीं US कंटीन्यूअस टेंस की जगह
उसका नॉर्मल टेंस बनाना प्रेसिडेंट है तो
प्रेजेंट पास्ट तो पास फीचर है तो फीचर आई
हॉप आपको यह कैंसर अब समझ में आई होगी फिर
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में संडे को
irregular अगर उसके साथ धन्यवाद